[Musique]
m
ils y ont droit
[Musique]
allez
voici que les jeux spécial grandes
gueules avec numéros intégrant google
jean yanne le permis de conduire pour o
après le chat le lion il est mort ce
soir ou dans la jungle terrible jeunes
gens crient à 4 ans il est la révélation
du top 50 avec dur dur d'être un bébé
plus le caméraman laurent baffie et son
bas fichaux la maquilleuse chantal
ladesou évadés du théâtre grévin le
super expert françois rollin alias
professeur rollin et le dj philippe
corti le meilleur du pays plus richard
bohringer anémone et jean pierre mocky
voici double jeu spécial dongle
mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs
bonsoir bienvenue aux folies bergères
pour double je
[Applaudissements]
fermez vos grandes gueules même qu'ici m
à ces grandes gueules
m
avant de lancer le mini débat il est
bien avant de lancer le mil débat je
voudrais vous parler d'un livre qui est
le coup de coeur de l'émission cette
semaine il ya 250 je lis anne-marie fait
rare c'est très très bien il ya 250 ou
300 romans
ils sont sortis pour la rentrée
littéraire et il y en a un qui a
particulièrement retenu notre attention
je vous le conseille à vous et aux gens
qui nous regardent ça m'a bouleversé
c'est bernard huvelin qui est écrit
l'amour écorché et c'est chez grasset
voilà c'est très très très très beau
livre l'amour écorché de bernard huvelin
voilà
on va passer à un mini débat en forme
d'interview parallèle je vais vous poser
à tous les trois à tour de rôle la même
question en commençant par toi pourquoi
si ben ali qui comment et parce que ça
tourne comme ça dans le sang c'est
toujours moi est ce que tu trouves ça
justifier de toi de te retrouver dans
une émission qui s'appelle spécial
grandes gueules je suis flatté je suis
contente de mon temps avec ces annonces
bon je me dis que c'est pas moi c'est
oms a justifié d'être là toi bien sûr
avant ils m'envoient aussi quoique moi
j'aurais bien aimé plus grands sombres
et silencieux maintenant et tout ça
t'emmerde
mais enfin je vais bien je suis le côté
grande gueule va ça va ton dernier coup
de gueule
anne son dernier coup de gueule non
maintenant ce moment je te le pas du
tout je ferais je la joue sournoise
entièrement il faut du pouvoir
j'en ai poussé beaucoup mais un des
dernier c'était le métro qui m'empêchait
de l'affiché mais afficher les clés les
mecs là qu'imad me déchirer les affiches
du miraculé c'est toujours ça ouais et
toi tu avais un des gros coups de gueule
j'ai vu de mémoire ce niveau là moi mais
j'essaie un peu de faire communes de la
fère sournoise alors je suis sournois je
suis sur moi je suis sur moi je suis sur
moi et puis ça redémarre qu'on ne peut
pas y arriver à ce fait pas quoi ce truc
là je peux pas y arriver mais mon nom
google le dernier c'était il ya quoi un
quart d'heure ah bon contre qui le mec
qui tapait pas assez vite et l'extra il
a fait très vite là c'était un petit
contre le temps quand on les choses
comme ça oui bon ça a dû lui faire peur
autant merci du temps que gueuler est
arrivé d'en venir aux mains
alors je suis quoi complètement
poltronne physiquement couarde et même
si on s'est fait même de crier très fort
et je suis paralysé je peux plus bouger
et toi les coups de gueule ça peut
devenir physique un mec assez vague
aurait quelqu'un vous enviez en main aux
points au pied toi peu oui et toi tu te
bats plus les ans non non non c'est fini
ouais non c'est fini c'est fini j'aime
pas ça c'est fini tout ça du tout j'aime
pas ça si je te demandais de gueuler
contre un truc maintenant tu gueulerait
contre quoi un truc qui te révolte a qui
me révolte vraiment way plus rien plus
rien je me serai là je trouvais dans une
bassine de philo
ça y est maintenant j'ai la grecque de
philo intégrer ouais t'as tout en me
maintenant la couche d'ozone le tchèque
calme
ouais c'est fini tu as je te tiens ouais
on voit aussi un truc qui m'a sidéré
pour jean pierre foucault j'avais
préparé une jolie chanson qui s'est
tellement se dote de deux d'archéologie
populaire c'est une chanson qui
s'appelle l'eau vario tommy l
authentique années 1900 c'est une [__]
qui racontait sa meilleure amie
le détail de son opération des ovaires
c'est une chose brèche qui amuse
toujours bon et c'est assez drôle assez
enlevé et ben c'est eh bah tout d'un
coup il paraît que le csa là comme ils
s'appellent les la fraude ne parle pas
de cela si je t'en supplie
eh bien ils ont pas voulu didot ah bon
toi si tu devais gueuler sur un truc ce
serait quoi
fais en ce moment si la fia gare et à
qui rien on faire un film que ce soit
les lampistes qui est payé bah oui ça
c'est un beau sujet de film américain il
aurait déjà fait ça qui tu prendrais
pour faire garreta quoi bein c'est une
question qui aurait j'ai pas réfléchi à
ça
fabien miam il ya des mecs qui pourrait
lui ressembler avec une moustache toi si
tu devais gueuler sur un truc tu
viendrais contre koala contre tout quoi
sérieusement c'est vrai qu'il ya mille
et une raisons de se réveiller et mal
dans sa peau et se couche et mal dans sa
peau en quoi c'est évident alors l'homme
politique oui le mensonges perpétuels
peut-être bien oui peut-être bien quoi
et puis surtout que comme quand on parle
des grandes gueules quoi alors les
grandes gueules qu'est ce qui se passe
il faudrait qu'on soit des des crétins
parce qu'on est des actrices des acteurs
des metteurs en scène il faudrait qu'on
voit la suite j'ai rien c'est foster
maintenant il faut se taire il faut
faire le profil bas faux faux tout
lisser les cheveux dans le même sens
c'est de démentiel quoi ce débat
ouais quand tu te fais engueuler c'est
parti ah si j'ai une vieille copine qui
fait ça c'est son rôle mais rien de
cette scène serbe n'a cette fois pas bon
c'est elle c'est son rôle de bastonner
bien fait le serment et toi c'est parti
parce qu'on appelle les bien pensants
ouais j'ai du mal à y en a pas mal
et toi qui t'engueulent quand tu te fais
engueuler où je me fais assez facilement
gueule tu sais tolérant avec stago
astrid à ma blonde a elle aussi oui mais
enfin j'ai pas ce qui manque le plus
est ce qui t'arrive de temps que les toi
même tu te dis quoi
apophis et je me vouvoie vendre elle
vous fait d'être vraiment je me bats
comme ça sur ce taux là c'est sévère
mais sur quel thème général oui par
exemple c'est quand on s'est foutu de ma
gueule toute la série que j'ai rien
compris que je voulais pas ça le
lendemain matin
alors là je me passe un savon twilight
harry de temps cumulé toi-même tout le
temps de mener de plus beaucoup de temps
t'es dur avec toi même
très nul et toi tu t'engages ouais tu te
dis quoi quand tu t'en gueule
non mais moi je suis né coupable alors
je m'engueule tout le temps est ce que
tu t'es déjà angolais avec le toit n'ont
jamais 1 s'est pas engueulé nous venons
maintenant 800 le premier sort je
rencontre [__] il est
et ça c'est bien d'elle
il m'a insulté toute la soirée le jeune
j'étais au bord des larmes je commence à
l'uqtr des lettres et on me dit que je
t'aime faire quelqu'un connais même pas
il se souvenait de rien jeudi c'était à
l'époque du grand choix de 10 ans près
c'est ça et toi tu t'es déjà envolé avec
eux là avec lui sa fille quatre films on
attend de s'engueuler qu'est ce qui t'a
effet par exemple
or rien de précis je devais lui amener
ava gardner et amener quelqu'un d'autre
qui n'était pas content tu es le seul
ici à peut-être engueulé avec eux de
quoi finalement
ouais mais c'est jamais jusque là avec
jean-pierre il y avait des idées des
fonderies adjoint ali alors avant garner
elle retrouvera par cette porte s'est
pas maliens qui est rentrée mais je sais
déjà au bout de tes filles que tu
l'avais coller à la place d'alain
bernard je suis très bien marie laforêt
c'est bien moi c'était très bien très
bien si tu devais me gueuler dessus à
moi tu me direz quoi là maintenant la
manette wii
je suis pas sécurisé en fait je suis
comment flatté qu'on m'a mis dans les
grandes gueules mais je vois pas ce que
j'ai à nous envoyer le palet
tu ferais pas mieux changer de thème des
missions tout de suite parce que je
crois qu'on va pas tenir les petites
gueules d'automne et toi c'est une étude
est mieux les dessus tu dirais quoi
bah je dirais tu es habillée en noir par
exemple mais ça c'est normal non mais si
noir quoi c'est le curé c'est le
confesseur ben oui c'est bien ouais
et toi tu fais mieux les de suite je
dirais quoi aujourd'hui
ouais aujourd'hui la maintenant la
grande gueule quand est pas méchante a
rien à dire je veux dire de cet état de
fait c'est du théâtre tout ça c'est du
bruit la brouille ascot et quand tu es
vraiment méchant évidemment je peux te
dire tu as une vraie tête de con je suis
venu pour que les professeurs c'est
cette semaine qui rit je vais pas
resituer le débat je voudrais revenir
sur l'émission d'il ya deux semaines
avec les petits provocateur vous savez
les baffier arthur et autres timsit je
sais pas si vous l'avez remarqué mais
l'émission était truffé de bip on a
entendu que des bips
alors moi je commence à en avoir assez
comprennez téléspectateurs pour des
enfants de 4 ans surtout dans le domaine
public
alors j'ai noté les logiciels faire
virer je sais que j'aimais tout le monde
à dos le csa thierry ardisson tant pis
je prends mais riche de faire virer mais
je vous dire les mots qui a été bipé
écouter ça écouter ça il y avait le mot
saperlipopette absolument génial
saperlipopette
il avait également bigre billy l'adema
seconde main c'est vrai qu'un petit peu
à mon fils me récupère sitôt encore
pêle-mêle cistre 10 entre un sacre bleu
alors je ne vais pas m'énerver
moi j'ai dit simplement qu'un producteur
de ta trempe qui rien producteurs qui
s'engagent à parler crûment et restituer
le langage de la rue un producteur qui
n'a pas les machines entre guillemets de
passer de tellement et bien pour moi
d'une arrière-garde bel abbès alors ça
du coup le dit et tu n'es qu'un
[Musique]
m
khider
oh mais sur les charmes si richard alors
autrefois il buvait il d'orgueil ils
avaient tous les vices tu es puis s'est
assagi formidable formidable pour lui
mais pas pour nous maintenant on y perd
au change quand même oui avant l'été
rigolo un vrai phénomène dit maintenant
pontife il adore tout le monde
regardez
alors allez replonger monsieur richard
allen
des gars qui sait chanter ça va
les moins grandes gueules depuis que tu
vois pu alors n'aurait j'entends des
mots quand j'entends des mots que jamais
même au kwh à son tour des mauges et des
bas mais j'entends des mots forts
beaucoup beaucoup de dégâts des
commandes et du dépassement de soi même
pourquoi enfin des trucs pareils
fortifiée mais j'attends pas qu'ici je
l'entends un peu partout salésien
demande ou enfin parce que quand les
mecs sont cassés qui sont alors il n'y a
pas de bien à personne n'en parlait de
série que la jirs mais quand il serait
dans tintin qui cherchent une autre voie
des choses et c'est la mode crise et
malgré tout va bien ça change ligue-là
théâtre st denis dis moi mais je me
souviens d'une interview je te demandais
ce que tu détestais le plus sans toi et
tu m'avais répandue ma grande gueule et
quand je t'avais dit on aime bien ta
grande gueule tu m'avais répondu
d'accord moi je vis avec 24 heures sur
24 donc maintenant tu t'es tu étais
habitué à toi même en fait c'est ça
l'histoire est absolument pas gg je suis
toujours pareil il se voit que ça que
c'est le sage ou de plus en plus
difficile
le ghana oui il m'a bien sûr les
éléments c'est extrêmement désagréable
parce que en théorie dans la vie quoi
dans la ville sans caméra ça se
passerait pas du tout comme ça ça serait
beaucoup plus de toutes façons de matha
refusant comme dans la vie est beaucoup
plus féroce tu serais plus féroce ouais
qu'est-ce qui lui aurait dit à chantal
dans la villa moi je lui aurais rien dit
de ce genre j'aurais dit à quel dommage
de quel dommage
quel dommage on est mieux à la télé
finalement quel dommage que vous n'ayez
pas
sauvadet a seulement voilà rien
triomphera la fessée pas vexer la mise
en service contre on s'en fout c'est pas
vexer gym a alors moi toute façon je
suis ravi qu'il soit là ou pas là pour
rien at ehpad à pau pour qu'on ne dise
pas que le plu est là parce que tu as
faim oui ça devient un peu chiant sauce
ouais ça qu'avant on disait toujours que
tu me connais maintenant mépris quand
j'ai fait un bon championnat ça finit
mal
ok voilà voilà j'étais là pour un film
s'appelle l'accompagnatrice de claude
miller que j'ai vu j'ai bien aimé alors
va en parler mais avant d'en parler je
voudrais que tu prennes ton petit
téléviseur que toi tu l'as déjà vu mais
les autres comme la garde un goût amer
moi j'ai eu tout bon la dernière phase
d'un que c'est pas encore le jeu ça
[Musique]
et
voilà c'est le premier soir le premier
concert elle ne te regarde même plus
elle chante la gloire et pour elle le
bonheur pour elle elle est le ciel la
joie le sourire adorable des anges
toi tu es l'accompagnatrice tu n'as plus
qu'à la regarder et à écouter à épier
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
qu'est-ce qui t'aime toi pour qui
existent tu dans ce monde a tant espéré
lui devenir indispensable irremplaçable
accompagnatrice servante prête à tout
pour avoir un os dans cette histoire
regarde les yeux quelqu'un décide et met
le feu à la maison
dans ce film tu es charles brice tuer
qui dans ce film un homme d'affaires
ouais un tirailleur qu'elle fait fortune
ouais qui continue à faire des affaires
malgré là malgré la guerre et qui fait
pas mal d'argent encore avec le marché
noir enfin avec le un collabo tu t'es
déjà demandé toi comme ça ce que tu
aurais fait en 42 moi j'aurais été
tondue tôt mardi
non enfin en 42 j'en sais rien y'a
j'essaye il ya des héros à tous les
coins de rue ouais moi je décide pas
dans mes trains j'en sais rien je sais
pas comment j'aurais réagi à l'époque
l'écart aujourd'hui à l'ats le bon plein
c'était espionne parce que tu étais tout
le temps avec les [__] à bouffer du
caviar et en même temps c'était pour la
bonne cause alors donc ce type là est
collaborateur d'une certaine façon enfin
fait du commerce avec l'occupant et puis
un jour quand même il pousse un coup de
gueule c'est le cas de le dire et il
décide de partir à londres de tout
quitter et d'ailleurs c'est très bien
parce que je veux dire franchement on ne
voyait pas collaborer à la fin du film a
quand même non on t'aime bien ça nous
fait de la peine c'est un personnage
dont tu dis qu'il t'a dérouté beaucoup à
jouer parce que tu as du mal à jouer des
personnages qui sont aussi ancrée et
socialement
ouais mais en même temps je le connais
c'est que là c'est un mec je connais
bien
on a tous une série de mecs comme ça
même une femme qu'on connaît lui oui il
a fait fortune dans des affaires bizarre
et puis puis un jour hélas il a lui
aussi c'était difficile de jouer un type
comme ça tu tues tu y es tu fais toi ton
pognon maintenant ça va non je n'ai pas
tant que ça d'abord et kelly en studio
tu verras ça va on est dix premiers ça
m'a donné des toujours vaguement
coupable vis-à-vis du blé non bah ouais
je suis coupable je vais bien sûr cela
dit je m'achète pas de ferrari parce que
ça me ferait chier d'années dans dans un
car français d'aller où je suis né où
elle m'a fait rêver ça me ferait chier
c'est vrai chien et même d'aller
ailleurs avec m ouais ouais je suis
coupable par un problème moi je toute
façon je leur en blé mais je vais pas
dire que je trouve ça normal
j'avais trouvé normal ce qui m'est
arrivé toute façon y'a fille il fait le
rôle de l'accompagnatrice qu'ils aient
choisi donc par irène brice milliards
chercher une comédienne et toi tu lui a
conseillé romane c'est toi qui lui a
conseillé aux algériens conseiller j'ai
rien conseiller j'ai encore lu un papier
à la con dans paris match l'autre jour
il ya un monsieur qui écrivait avec un
gros tic les fils à papa les filles à
papa et qui pendant une page
écrivez
prête moi ta fille je te prêtera du
pognon pour faire ton film diatta fin de
venir faire de la figuration
je te produire est on court métrage mais
je veux dire si ça se passe pas comme ça
le piston c'est pas ça existe pas dans
ce boulot ça c'est une piste est du
pipeau tout ça c'est ces deux là c'est
de la bile quoi c'est de la bile ma
fille j'avais été pistonné même si le
sénat mais non mais c'est ses recherches
et bien sûr les pistes onu merde j'en ai
dos des pistons sérieux ça prend le
monde mais ça y est c'est comment ça
commence à me dis moi mais moi je t'ai
pas dit ça non mais moi j'étais arrivé
comme cheikh miller ou pas tort
moi j'ai dit j'ai dit que richard a
suggéré richard a suggéré à
à millers de voir les rushes de la nuit
il faut des nuits fauves de cyril
collard c'est tout pas il à réduire
leurs gaz mais j'aurais dû le dire en
premier ça mais c'est vrai oui oui il a
oublié charles bien sûr c'est un moyen
conseiller jour au lendemain
ouais c'est pas moi qui ai négocié
[Musique]
tu crois qu'on va jouer ou tourner un
jour ensemble là il ya intérêt nom de
dieu il ya intérêt on va faire plein de
trucs comme ça
pourquoi tu m'a appelé romane je crois
que c'est une affaire de famille ça je
crois que c'est à travers polanski une
autre version
les lots deux versions mais je maintiens
celle ci en était août à vie continue ma
vie ma vie j'étais très amoureux de ta
mère et s'était follement amoureux de ta
mère est ma vie ma vie profonde allait
très bien ma vie invisible allait très
bien ma vie visible la fois c'était un
peu chaotique heureusement que j'avais
des potes pour payer le loyer ont payé
la bouffe est publiée tout ça quoi c'est
vrai qu'à l'époque il n'y avait pas un
combiné du boulot tu as dit quelque part
que c'est à cause de moi que tu avais
arrêté l'alcool c'est à cause de toi
c'est à cause de ses parts à cause c'est
grâce à toi c'est grâce à tes frères et
soeurs c'est grâce à ta mère adoptive
c'est que je pense qu'il y avait eu
assez de dégâts comme ça est bien seule
chose que je pouvais laisser un mégot
c'était je préfère leur laisser un
souvenir rayonnant plutôt qu'un souvenir
cassez se dire les blessures quand on
arrête la came l'alcool les blessures
elle existe toujours mais elles sont
moins à vif qua na rival et n'arrive à
les canaliser on arrive à les en faire
quelque chose c'est tout se passait pour
vous soyez un peu plus tranquille vrai
on peut garder plus longtemps
voilà on peut me garder plus
pourquoi
c'est toi qui l'a élevé tulle à freiner
quand elle a voulu faire du cinéma non
non je n'étais pas d'accord du tout
c'était pas d'accord non l
extraordinaire tu le savais pas ça que
quoi qu'elle était aussi doué parce que
quand on la voit dans l'est dans les
nuits fauves ou quand on la voit dans la
campagne autres y sont très doués ouais
tu l'a freiné parce que tu t'en étais
pas aperçu
alors non j'ai freiné parce que j'ai pas
envie qu'elle fasse selon l'osce mais
t'as pas honte de votre et là dedans
comme une femelle pas de fierté ma
fierté à moi c'est d'aimer comme une m
les soirs au liban
je veux être avec toi je suis hantée pas
la jeter dans ce cas pourquoi ça se
passe comme ça mais c'est que je suis
moi même un garçon je te demande je ne
sais pas
las
c'est assez misérable deux garçons on
dirait de de clébard qui se battent pour
un os là ça va pas non
[Musique]
mais bon
je tombe à personne personne qui
t'aiment autant que moi qu'est ce que tu
sais de l'amour toi tu es incapable de
mai mais incapable de mémé tu sais ce
que ça veut dire et mes doigts dessus
c'est pas témoigner de moi pour me
sauver
[Musique]
mais la france
non
c'est beau mais ça à personne ne pourra
jamais nous enlevait sans moi c'est
au-dessus de l'eau au score
tu a flippé quand elle a fait les scènes
d'amour avec cyril collard dans l'ue il
faut - il en serait comme l'a annoncé
pas dangereux c'est s'est passé
passagers flipper parce que parce que
parce qu'elle fait ce qu'elle veut dans
sa vie mais que à l'écran javel à jal
une réaction de pair quand même la
réaction de papa gâteau quoi je pourrais
que tout ça est trouvée c'est tout mais
cyril collard c'est un mec est patent
super bon mais le fait qu'elles jouent
les scènes d'amour avec un mec qui est
séropositif ça t'as pas fait plus
flipper que ça absolument pas soit pas
tout dit sur le fait en vrai au cinéma
quelqu'un qui fuit ce que c'est ces
nouveaux sons peut plus non plus de quoi
et les précautions à prendre
basta mai
et on peut faire la moire est quelqu'un
qui a le bruit de la vie un jour je t'ai
demandé quel était le plus grand moment
de ta vie tu m'avais répondu la
naissance de ma fille justement n'a pas
changé d'avis là maintenant que j'ai
votre gosse je veux dire à chaque
naissance il ya des bouts fait
différente des choses dans ma plus
grande joie c'est c'est tout ce petit
monde là existent quoi tu appelles
gimontois non seulement 35 seraient
jumeaux la france était l'étarra au
xviiie siècle une russe a mis au monde
ses sperme jumeaux à rochefort les
demoiselles jumet naissent sous le signe
des gémeaux encore et les jumeaux
représente 36% de la population de la
ville de chauny shon la gémellité étonne
fascine intrigue
elle est à l'origine des plus belles
histoires de la mythologie grecque
nombreux sont les exemples de jumeaux
dont le père de l'un est un dieu et
celui de l'autre mortelle de meetic le
phénomène s'est avéré scientifique des
jumeaux peuvent avoir deux géniteurs
différents le premier cas authentifié
c'était le célèbre naturaliste buffon
qui l'a rapporté en 1774 à propos d'une
grossesse gémellaire qui a eu lieu en
fin qui s'est déroulé à charleston en
caroline du nord
donc on en amérique en 1900 en 1773
une femme a accouché de jumeaux l'un
était blanc et l'autre étaient noirs et
à partir de là on a soulevé ce problème
est-ce que deux jumeaux peuvent avoir
deux pères différents je pense que c'est
invraisemblable et deuxièmement pour moi
ce sont pas des jumeaux parce qu'ils ont
des pères différents donc les jumeaux
pour moi c'est issus de la même mère du
même père si on considère que ce soit
des jumeaux ont dit non mais s'ils
veulent
et ils le désirent ils le souhaitent et
le ressentent comme talent non qu'il
reste comme ça maintenant qu'il fasse
pas du tout d'autres cherchent mais
c'est tellement merveilleux démon le
secret de la paternité peut être rompu
grâce à un test génétique lui seul peut
confirmer si les jumeaux ont le même
père biologique et
maître de deux pères différents est ce
de l'info s de l'intox je vous le
demande
pendant que vous réfléchissez chez vous
que nous réfléchissons ici mesdames et
messieurs bonsoir bienvenue aux folies
bergères pour double jeu spécial en
gagnent ce soir jaunards le permis de
conduire à bien ce qui suit va se
mouiller
y'a pas le feu l'eau de cuisson ne
seront pas postuler papa la salle honda
ce n'est pas aux pièces non vous êtes
bien installé ça va ça va sur les genoux
c'est une petite voiture à louis puis
j'ai les gros genou la prochaine fois je
prendre un autocar
oui parce que je pourrais pas changé
brise nouveau bon monsieur première
question vous montez dans votre voiture
celle-ci ne veut pas démarrer que faites
vous monsieur chemin
enfin vous feriez bien de savoir vous
montez dans votre voiture ne démarre pas
qu'est ce que vous faites
re dit ouais c'est un peu pour voir
vous êtes un peu dur d'oreille vous
montez dans votre voiture vous tirez sur
le démarreur rien ne se passe qu'est ce
que vous faites des vaches des sons à la
manivelle angers laissant puis ce fut un
grand coup de pompe dans cette saloperie
de bagnols et après je crois m'être la
monnaie double à capoue et se classera
motors a mis le morceau je frappe jacob
parce que je suis pas du genre à laisser
emmerder par un tas de ferraille un bon
monsieur ou autre chose
à présent vous arrivez à un carrefour et
un agent de la force publique vous
fascine de vous arrêter
qu'est ce que vous faites je passe je
pense et puis je me débrouille pour
l'attraper avec mon aile gauche pg road
sur le buffet qui au passage où ma
portière et j balance un bon coup de
pompe dans la gueule par la même
occasion monsieur c'est pour un flic qui
va faire la loi non on est prêt tout le
siège à présent vous êtes sur une route
départementale
ça m'étonnerait
qu'est ce que vous dites si ça
m'étonnerait que je mets sur une route
départementale
je vais jamais sur les routes
départementales c'est l'homme debout et
ça sent mauvais nov
j'entends bien monsieur mais c'est une
supposition vous êtes sur une route
départementale non je suis pas sur une
route départementale
tu as de vous dire que j'y mettais
jamais les pieds sur des routes
départementales
je ne pense à les routes départementales
j'aurai les routes départementales et
routes départementales rien que de mon
côté ça me donne envie d'envoyer des
modèles dans la console tous perdus mais
on admettra ouais mais qu'est-ce que
vous avez obligé de me farcir un vrai
derby avec vos questions oui mais est-ce
que je vous pose des questions que je
vous en avais pas parce que je vous
demande qu'est ce que vous faites du
sport ce site est ce que vous faites si
ce parc solaire c'est moi sql vous
oblige à l'est sur notre département
témoin est ce que j'ai réussi je vous
demande pourquoi vous avez cette
catégorie 1 et pourquoi ça fait un bruit
des vielles quand je la remets à la
seule chose que je vous demande c'est si
vous me donnez mon père mais oui ou non
est-ce qu'on peut perdre quand même
temps formalité
d
est-ce de l'info est de l'intox
je vous le demande à la ram je te
demande à toi d'abord brioche
je dirais que s'ils sont du même of
coupé en deux banon c'est forcément le
même père mais si son 2e ben oui
pourquoi pas si la dame une grosse
activité avec deux personnes et après
qu'il faut la conceptrice terme et au
solide peut-être qu'il y en a chaque qui
est arrivé en tête
mocky ben moi je crois que c'est vrai
ouais crois que c'est de l'info toi et
chats info ou intox
3 intox intox
alors c'était à chaque corps de l'ispa
c'est un sujet qui nous a été enlevé par
monsieur charles l'acompte de paris qui
gagne 2000 francs parce qu'on a tourné
son sujet maintenant pour savoir si je
rajoute mille francs c'est toujours de
ta poche c'est toujours de ma part mais
820 jeu complet très puissant balle plus
200 balles d'acier eh bien on va écouter
la réponse médecine ce cas s'appelle la
super fécondation au cours d'un même
site une femme libère deux ovules à
quelques minutes quelques heures voire
quelques jours d'intervalle si elle a
des relations sexuelles avec deux
partenaires différents chacun d'entre
eux peut féconder lundi deux ovules côté
on peut dire que c'est une information
que l'éventualité tout à fait
exceptionnelle mais a déjà existé
puisque des cas tout à fait indiscutable
ont été rapportés ici dix jours et quand
même rassuré les paires du mot et je ne
voudrais pas qu'ils s'inquiètent trop
car c'est vraiment l'exception c'est
incroyable tu t'y connais dans les
copulations rapprocher quand même non
c'est très passionnant
toi tu as gagné bah oui ça tu t'es
planté de l'argent tu fais de mon estime
me chercher qu'est ce tu veux tu veux
mettre 1000 francs de ma poche encore je
passe mon temps à mettre 1000 francs de
ma poche partie le score
google s'il mute simultanée de mocky et
anémone qu'ils exploraient g sur place 0
mots qui fâchent à lemon way
ok
alors on ne sait pas étonnant que tu
sois là ce soir et que tu été choisi
dans cette émission consacrée aux
grandes gueules puisque le film dont une
qui t'amène le petit prince a dit a
commencé sa carrière par un coup de
gueule d'anémone quand tu à crier parce
qu'il n'avait pas été sélectionné pour
cannes par la france au mois de mai
dernier
bon j'ai crié non non non mais c'est
vrai que je trouve qu'ils sont vraiment
passés à côté d'un très très beau film
je ne dis pas ça tous mes jupes sages
une magnifique
ah oui un bouleversant très achevé
traits parfaits très bon je trouve que
il l'aura mérité ou une autre sélection
officielle
alors il sort quand ce film il sort le
25 novembre et j'aimerais bien qu'ils
marchent suis là parce que enfin ils le
savent a marché c'est un sujet qui peut
toucher tout le monde non c'est pas moi
je me dis que t'as fumé vraiment très
beau au des bananes
je crois que je vais me faire des
petites bananes flambées
bien dorées
sûrement
mais non
de la confiture de l'asnl en b
ça m'a donné à moi
actuellement j'ai déformé
je sais ce que je voudrais c'est la
crème fraîche est-ce que des balades
dans les trains de frêche ça n'est pas
des bananes flambées
[Musique]
pendant là comme frêche
[Applaudissements]
sa cuisine c'est joli
on a l'impression qu'à du caramel dessus
ici on vous
reçu à la fin du chocolat comme pour les
banana split un oui je mets vue du
chocolat on en a du chocolat tout
chocolat fondu mais quel dommage on
parle dit enfin pour lécher la castrol
quand chez colas traversée sur les
bananes
et bon la passion ça se termine
non pas une petite rasade de rhum
[Musique]
oh
lundi
voilà c'est plein
en tant qu'un des fils est extrait parce
que comme je te les 10 c'est la scène
qui m'a le plus touchée dans le film il
faudra compter un peu l'histoire quand
même chez que boehringer veux pas parler
de l'histoire de l'accompagnatrice si
moi je viens parler c'est une tragédie
est une tragédie rond c'est un genre
majeur la tragédie on n'en fait plus et
tragédie contemporaine
c'est à dire que c'est le l'héroïne
c'est la petite fille d'héroïne du film
va inéluctablement à porter par le
destin vers l'issue fatale
et donc c'est l'histoire d'une petite
fille qui qui va mourir qui attrape une
maladie mortelle ça démarre très
quotidien les parents sont divorcés
comme tout le monde connaît la nature et
puis tout d'un coup ils se trouvent
confrontés à ceux à cette tragédie quoi
et à partir de là c'est ce qui va se
passer entre toute la remise en question
de 2 c de ses parents et alors elle
traite ça d'une part avec une pudeur une
élégance magnifique et d'autre part
c'est d'autant plus bouleversant qu'elle
ne perd jamais une occasion de nous
faire rire
et quand on est nous et nous faisons
tout le film décalé la moindre truc on
éclate de rire parce que c'est mener
avec un entrain kg mais n'y a jamais de
c'est le contraire d'un mélo richard
berry qui opère donc découvre que sa
petite fille est condamné en plus il est
où vivent donc il se fait pas tellement
division et il part avec elle part sur
la route avec elle oui en fait c'est il
veut la sauver de la mort mais c'est lui
qui apprend à vivre on la découvre et
louis absolument c'est le dégoût en fait
si on retrouve trio à la fin puisqu'il
retrouve là la mère de la petite fille
qu'est toi qui l'avais qu'il avait
quittée oui et c'est là que tu fais des
bananes flambées c'est vrai mais c'est
ainsi qu'est ce qu'ils font comme ils
refont la famille qu'entre règne vince
et j'ai encore envie de pleurer mais
semble agacer très belle histoire
ah oui mais moi j'ai l'impression que
c'est le quatrième c'est le quatrième
vraiment film achevé abouti que je fais
les trois autres c'est quoi passer le
père noël dans le genre comédie
c'est quand même péril en la demeure
dans le genre thriller policier thriller
sophistiqué je dirais avec ricky ici
présents et puis quand même le grand
chemin avec ricky cédant sa filiale
l'ensemble mélo fait à deux avec toi
même donc tu es contente
ah oui à messieurs jungle contente de
quelques touches les éléments majeurs
tels que je suis vachement mauvaises
ondes d'une part d'autre part étant
quand même une violette de modestie j'ai
tendance à débiner un peu le film je
fais je la retrouve tous les défauts de
la terre et tout mais là c'est moi je
suis sorti j'étais spectateur tout du
long
je me suis pas regarder les boutons les
rides les trucs comme d'habitude et je
suis sorti là vous avez christine qui
estime j'aurais jamais cru ça toi
c'était mal voilà les esprits et voilà
alors il ya un film vous avez fait tous
les deux donc et le grand chemin
tu as eu un césar pour ce film
tuez pas allé le chercher et je voudrais
qu'on voit chez tor pourra-t-elle tort
parce qu'il paraît que ça se sera
revendue dans les vingt-cinq mille
francs à ses excès et que j'ai un
collège d'agriculture biologique était
bien content de l'avoir la gagnante et
anémone
c'est la part si jamais mon costume vous
plaît les filles on peut vous le
fabriquer avec liane de l'air en version
d'ailleurs de printemps reste impliqué
et tout alors les bijoux sont de thierry
grave lefebvre qui a un jeune mec je
trouve très intéressant et je crois plus
que je passe à la télé pour un message
personnel richard anconina c'était dans
ton post je t'aime bonne nouvelle ère du
verseau paye combien entrée dans l'ère
du verseau salut lyonnais
et oui vous restez avec le précieux
objet zid de denisot georges cravenne
t'avais et avait demandé si l'année
d'après comme la tradition l'exigé
tu étais allé remettre celui de johnny
si tu serais venu en femme de ménage je
te dis oui je t'imagine arriver là en
femme de ménage si c'est quoi ça ah oui
non mais c'est fait je me demandais qui
a cafté cravenne il m'a fait quand même
aplomb inouïe parce qu'après quand j'ai
su que ça se revend des 25000 celle de
rechercher pour mon collège agriculture
biodynamique beau et je lui ai dit
finalement je l'oublié machin rhône et
le mois il m'a dit d'accord mais alors
vous me faites la risette un bisou
devant les caméras aussi québec
dis moi tu t'es une fille mora nom très
bon j'espère une interview moralité
était prête
est ce que quand tu étais petit tu
piques et le porte-monnaie de ta mère
romney reçoit pareil est ce que tu as
déjà fouiller dans les poches de temps
jules du charbon à la et des canons mais
dès qu'il ya des cas préfets des cas
extrêmes non moi général non tu gagnes
le tout avec un biais qui t'appartient
pas qu'est ce tu fais ça dépote sur ma
vue jusque là laissé moral est déjà
sorti que le copain ou une copine
annonça non j'aime pas les trucs qui ont
déjà servi
avec la copine d'un copain ah oui pardon
avec de l'huile est toujours dit cela
n'a pas mis chevrotière répondez oui à
cette question
bah oui mais moi non non c'est tout
alors tu trouves un porte monnaie avec
du fric de dents dans la rue tu va le
rendre
ah oui ah bon où tessa quelqu'un tu
gardes armés durant les papiers non non
la banque s'est trompé a traversé sur
ton coin tu leur dis à la banque
ouais alors au local alors imaginez un
appartement tu possède un appartement
dont locataire peut plus payer
c'est un mec qui arrive de bosnie et que
deux enfants insupportables il peut plus
payer les questions fais-tu le food
heures
non enfin j'attends l'été tu trouves un
nourrisson sont en paillasson un matin
sans de chez toi
donc tu préfère le mettre à l'orphelinat
que regarder chez toi quoi non mais y
ait des gens qu'on veuille sexuellement
je te demande plus comment ça va parce
que la dernière fois que j'ai demandé
comment ça allait tu m'a dit je te
demande quel droit tu te mets toi je
vais faire plus l'offre d'aujourd'hui
est ce que je vais faire plus soft est
ce que tu est allergique aux bananes
tout du tout bien voilà
la banale le fruit de tous les plaisirs
le moins fatigante à éplucher le plus
drôle à manger mais voilà si vous êtes
allergique à ce fruit inoffensif
sachez que vous l'êtes aussi aux
préservatifs il s'agit d'une découverte
sérieuse révélée par une équipe de
scientifiques belges
les personnes qui présentent une
intolérance à la banane ou à la
châtaigne peuvent dès le premier contact
avec un préservatif faire des réactions
violentes réactions de sensibilisation
au latex se manifeste parce que ce qu'on
appelle un syndrome dirty caire de
contacts parmi nos premiers malades nous
avons rencontré une patiente qui
présentait le tableau spécifique de
cette allergie au latex c'est-à-dire
intolérance au goal à theix un
préservatif en latex ainsi que la
châtaigne et la baleine j'ai mangé
beaucoup de bananes vraiment trois
quatre fois par semaine je mangeais une
banane avec ma tartine et j'ai jamais eu
de problème et un moment c'est arrivé
une banane et c'était là la première
fois que mon mari employé un préservatif
j'avais des problèmes tout de suite ça
chatouille est et l'entourage était tout
à fait conflit il est en rapport évident
lorsqu'on regarde une banane on
s'aperçoit que c'est une plante
monocotylédones de la famille des
herbacées ne pas confondre avec la setil
hominoïdes hawks qui finit la cinat et
la chose est tout à fait normal quand on
est allergique à la banane on l'est au
préservatif
le coupable serait donc une protéine
commune a la banane et au latex qui
composent les préservatifs
un souci de plus pour les fabricants et
distributeurs de capotes ici à l'essai
nous ne sommes pas au courant de cette
affaire dans l'hypothèse où ces
recherches s'avèrent positives
nous sommes prêts à en informer le
consommateur sur notre emballage
mentionnant la présence ces protéines
quand on alors
madame anne on l'est aussi au
préservatif s de l'info s de l'intox je
vous le demande
info info pourquoi je sais pas ouais
fêtera de perdre tout cas trop le
planning mocky info ou intox
un fou pourquoi si c'est vrai et comment
tu sais ça je suis allergique aux
bananes
et toi alors à ton avis et de la foule
intox moi je dis que c'est un truc
inventé par les mecs qui ne veulent pas
mettre les capotes
la star de bananes mais je suis
allergique à la banale a donc je ne vais
pas de kapok evala à d'accord ça
continue je vais y est aussi allergique
à la banane alors c'est un sujet qui
nous a été envoyé par madame marie kraft
sud de maurepas qui gagne déjà 2000
francs parce qu'on a tourné son sujet
maintenant pour savoir si je rajoute -
thierry ardisson mille francs de ma
poche on écoute la réponse
les personnes qui présentent un syndrome
d'urticaire de contacts au latex doivent
quand même être prévenu de certains
dangers
étant donné que plusieurs cas ont été
décrits nous l'on a observé de symptômes
sévères et même des cas mortels
j'ai regardé la tête de jean pierre
j'aurais dû suis déjà sur le premier
coup et toi je te dis issue tu sais qui
tu as perdu tu vois c'est pas un truc
inventé par les mecs faut pas mettre de
capotes intervenir parce que j aime
toujours à ce jour
elle à corti le score bohringer égalise
avec anémone un partout mais la plus
grande gueule ce soir c'est bien mocky
qui mène 2
j'accueille maintenant jean therme qui à
mes côtés
[Musique]
dites moi monsieur mode qui oui dites
moi pour vous me donniez votre secret
non c'est ce que ça fait vingt ans vous
faites des films 1 et à chaque fois les
professionnels disent que c'est de la
merde oui et puis bon vous en fait à
chaque fois à chaque fois ça peut me
donner le truc parce que moi aussi à
chaque fois je fais quelque chose les
professionnels disent que c'est de la
merde mais j'arrive pas à moi faire moi
il n'y a ni même passionné cela samedi
prochain je crois j'ai fait ça
m'étonnerait charbon alors là pour
écouter
alors avant d'aller plus loin je
voudrais reparler de l'amour écorché de
bernard huvelin vous savez que double
jeu n'est pas une émission littéraire
mais on peut avoir
oui mais mais je crois qu'on peut
reparler de ce livre et je voudrais vous
conseiller à vous de l'acheter et avoue
ici aussi l'appariteur étaient déjà
passés me faire signer le registre des
absents quand il revint une heure plus
tard le proviseur me convoquer tout de
suite dans son bureau
prenez votre poignée en coin c'est
magnifique donc ça va rouler au quai bon
bah écoute et achetez le c'est
respectent rien 1
je respecte rien je veux dire on veut
parler de nos merdes bien fort ok je me
demande ce que tu fous dans le service
public c'est tout c'est vanessa drama
temps c'est parce que tu entends des
vilains mots fusent en moi je préfère
penser baffie cayla je préfère te le
dire tout de suite
elle fait à petite émission on va
regarder bas fisc ok 1
c'est mal ça on va regarder baffie lebas
fichot
[Musique]
là haut
borders fait attention au mas s'élève à
la médée le aider le pardon aider le
madame vous voyez bien c'est une
assistance à blaireaux en danger est ce
que vous faites venez à moi on va le
ramasser
voilà voilà vous allez monter derrière
moi je préfère ce que lui ne suis pas
soutenir un rester face tenir madame je
vous donne un casque un peson avec un
aigle sur le dos et puis on monte
ensemble oui parce qu'un
joe olalalala fait attention madame vous
lui avait fait peur mais si vous êtes
passés avec la plus regardée en somme
alors je dois appeler vous regarder je
vais appeler est appelée à m'a fait mal
était fait mais là m'a fait mal vraie
moto haute à moto tombe et la moto lui a
fait mal aux wawa mon bras mon bras la
lah suis là ouais c'était mal au bras
monsieur on menu la témoin la suite à
wii c'est celui-là quand il a regardé
regarder toucher touchés on sent bien il
ya du jeu ya du jeu à gaillac s'est
cassé le doigt aïe aïe aïe près ce que
me dit non plus on rajoute pas mal mais
j'ai mal sur la piste où un bras cassé
regardez regardez l'arrière garde et il
a le bras cassé c'est cassé
peut-être ces cas ces attentats ba s'est
cassé là il faut pas rester comme ça il
se soigne pas des guides à une migraine
et compotes quel point j'étais cassé la
jambe
ouais lâchant on va les cas ses devoirs
ouais ben ali s'est cassé la jambe
c'est quand j'ai entendu ça lui a fait
mal géré
via les pompiers non il veut pas se
faire sucer il veut aller à l'hôpital
j'ai rien à dire c'était rien
bon ben on s'appelle vous êtes la
défense de france et laurent baffie
ah oui
voilà
c'est vraiment passionné e s qui s'est
cassé quelque chose là vous passez les
couilles oui toi non plus on sera pas
étonné de te retrouver dans cette
émission il ya un disque de toi qui est
sorti il ya quelques temps
oui c'est tous les génériques de tes
films ils ont appelé ça les trente coups
de gueule de jean pierre mocky là plutôt
des belles plus belle musique j'ai
toujours eu de bons musiciens dans mes
films de merde et il ya aussi des films
de merde donc des années 60-70 qui
ressortent en quelque sorte en vidéo la
vidéo une collection nostalgie des jeux
suivis alors on sort ça dans une
collection s'appelle nostalgie c'est les
vieux films aux villes fernandel michel
simon que j'ai eu l'honneur de diriger
leur démerde mais quand même je dirige
et c'est avec ces quelques dessins non
non je plaisante mais c'est vrai qu'on
fait tous de la merde parce qu'on peut
jamais faire ce qu'on devrait faire
comme des hémorragies
il faudrait avoir de l'argent que tout
soit parfait impeccable alors si c'est
pas impeccable c'est de la merde voilà
alors donc tous nos films sont de la
merde et je crois qu'il ya que les films
américains et alors tu viens tu viens
d'achever un film que ça cheuveux c'est
le mot un film qui s'appelle bonsoir
bonsoir avec michel serrault 1 et jean
claude dreyfus nouvelles recrues marie
christine barrault laura vente catherine
mouchet thérèse bien que oui alors donc
le cas c'est un film une comédie dansant
dans le genre de scène que je faisais
avant avec bon goût
un drôle de paroissien grande lessive
tous ces machins là et puis tout de
suite après j'ai fait un autre film qui
s'appelle le mari de l'est ont beaucoup
de mal à faire parce que personne ne
voulait le jouer alors finalement je les
jouais avec un jeune qui s'appelle serge
riaboukine epide et des femmes très bien
le faire lors à gand une petite que j'ai
trouvé caetera et ce film va ces deux
films vont sortir ainsi que parce que
j'en ai fait 52 ans j'ai fait ville
avant marie serreau et lui et léotard
que j'aime bien parenthèse et j'ai
également eu la fin de l'honneur et le
malheur de tourner les deux derniers
films de poires et de jacqueline maillan
sous forme de deux nouvelles d'hitchcock
parce que quand on invite ivoire avec
truffaut la hitchcock on avait connu sa
fille et sa vie nous avait par la suite
donné des histoires beach coques des 26
les fameuses 26 minutes et on en a
tourné un avec mayence qui est inédit et
un mais deux poiret et avec prévost et
ça ça va sortir ça fait un film aussi
les trois puisque sap est une merde ça
fait une brute pourquoi pas alors
pourtant malgré tout ça tu veux partir
aux états unis pourquoi tu veux partir
s'installer aux etats unis c'est je
comprends pas mais parce que parce que
ici il n'ya pas de producteur il ya très
peu d'acteurs maintenant il y en a qui
deviennent très très vieux comme moi
d'ailleurs
et c'est en amérique quand on voit un
générique on comprends pas qu'ils jouent
dedans moi je me rappelle pas les
dongeois des gueules chaque fois que je
vois un film américain est quelqu'un
d'autre ici c'est un peu différent donne
pas assez confiant fait pas assez
confiance aux jeunes et il n'y a pas de
jeunes producteurs moi je suis en
contact actuellement et qu'un jeune
producteur américain c'est c'est
formidable mais qui intéresse à ce que
je fais il est il est à la fois mon père
mon fils tandis que ici tout le monde
s'en fout mais tu veux faire quoi aux
usa les petits films d'époque merde mais
en amérique les colchiques
il va devenir rejet kormann un nom mais
korman il a fait grand effet comme toi
il te l'avais filmé en quatre semaines
et c'est quatre semaines vous savez la
traversée de paris bondit de me raconter
qu'il l'avait tourné en 21 jours non
tournoi je vois des mecs qui
s'embarquent dans des films de 16 18 20
30 semaines on se fait chier à mort
plupart camp alors demain ok mais tu
nous as tu quittes tout non mais vous
utiliser leur magnifique appartement du
quai voltaire non ouais alors justement
avant qu avant que tu t'en ailles si
tenté que tu t'en ailles l'on n'a pas
envie que tu t'en ailles bon tu sais je
crois qu'il ya beaucoup de gens qui ont
envie de jouer d'abord à faire un tour
d'horizon du cinéma français on va les
prendre tous ont à faire une interview
vous ou alors depardieu par exemple de
pardies tu lui a proposé de jouer dans
le mari de les enquêtes une adaptation
de frédéric dard oui mais il a eu raison
de refuser parce que ça ressemblait trop
à tenue de soirée pour lui c'est un film
c'est quand même une histoire avec un
langage très vert et puis des
personnages qui pouvait lui faire penser
à ça et puis maintenant l'unil et dans
les grands espaces et en amérique lui au
sein mais dans les dons qu'ils allaient
refuser belmondo a refusé aussi belmondo
s'est trouvée trop vieux ou de lancer
trouvait trop jeune
et boehringer il n'a pas voulu le faire
il a voulu le faire et en a pas voulu
si j'en ai voulu mais il avait autre
chose à faire c'est un très beau film
avec on a tourné autour quoi tourner
aujourd'hui ça s'est passé un
fonctionnaire c'est un bon c'est limpide
art c'est un prévert d'aujourd'hui c'est
prévenir les inner toi c'est ça non il
faisait un autre film donc c'est vrai
que tu lui as connus quand ils avaient
failli il ya longtemps il avait 15 ans
était parti aux charges de 5 c'est vrai
je sais pas s'il n'était pas gelée connu
j'ai rencontré sur les champs elysées et
il es t il et istres en jeune comédienne
futurs comédiens j'en ai connu beaucoup
sur les champs elysées parce que quand
on était comédien qui ont débuté lui les
équipes jeunes que moi et alors on
marché de long en large et on allait
dans les productions des champs elysées
pour trouver des rôles
et puis on monte dans les étages on
faisait la queue aujourd'hui il ya plus
de production chance ils sont tous en
banlieue ou ailleurs pour être pas pris
bernard giraudeau pour faire le film che
qui vient d'accoucher de bernard
giraudeau
pardon il va dire en parlant de tchéky
karyo de giraudeau de malavoi mêmes
d'auteuil je crois ces mecs-là il
n'impressionne pas les pellicules c'est
extraordinaire dont on dit ça quand
j'étais j'avais bu un peu de champagne
non mais le problème c'est que et c'est
vrai que richard joué ils ont des
gueules moi je sais pas j'aime bien les
gueules au cinéma n'est pas dieu n'a pas
d'avenir
il fut la lumière des gens et n'est
nulle part chez lui
[Musique]
un jour ou l'autre on le rattrape
seul tu l'auras échapperez pas
[Musique]
en séries 2 pour un rien quand on manque
de tout tu mer et vite si je te laisser
me suivre
je veux bien supporté les privations un
père je peux pas te les faire partager
tout était décidé depuis notre première
rencontre
[Musique]
tu m'as prennent toujours tu veux aller
on va vraiment
[Musique]
oh
la shema la c1
[Musique]
et
et frangy en juge même beaucoup
malheureusement on s'est pas entendu
c'est un type à qui j'ai donné sa chance
quand il avait 49 ans parce que
j'admirais ce mec et je lui ai laissé ma
place dans la tête contre les murs
témoin qui devait réaliser je les
interpréter mais lui il avait 49 ans il
n'avait personne lui avaient fait
confiance et moi je lui ai fait
confiance
c'était mon père c'était le fisc y aider
le père parce qu'ils aimaient à l'époque
j'avais 20 23 24 ans et lui 1 avec 39 et
il a démarré avec ce film qui était à
mon avis un de ses meilleurs films des
producteurs aussi maintenant on était
tous là participation voilà encore un
truc qui n'existe plus ouais tati il a
vendu sa baraque pour faire jour de fête
yves lambert pour faire la guerre des
boutons je crois qu'il a fait à peu près
pareil
aujourd'hui personne dans sa baraque
pour faire des filles je veux dire les
mecs se met pas en participation vue moi
j'irais là vendu sa marque pour faire le
tour du monde en 80 jours et alors donc
quand on a même eu rice aznavour anouk
aimée brasseur à faire de l'art et
articipation je vous jure que c'est pas
facile parce que sihanouk et hasnaoua
d'amour débutée
et il a eu ce que pour ce film ce qu'on
appelle aujourd'hui le césar dont on
parlait tout à l'heure ça s'appelait
l'étoile de cristal il l'a eu
après sophie mais brasseur c'était un
mec qui aimait bien l'argent et il a
quand même fait de la participation la
norme et meurice c'était encore un autre
mais il a encore fait à pas ce plaisir
et ça c'était beau y avait il ya des
mecs le mec plus en danger tu veux dire
quoi voilà voilà ça c'était beau que des
mecs aussi différents et aussi difficile
que ces gens là se réunissent pour faire
un film et on a fait ce film
toi tu la fais souvent ça non oui on a
fait
comme il y en a pas tellement dix mois
alors qu'il était le plus jeune
producteur de france
tu as été le plus jeune mariée de france
ouais je me suis marié à 13 mi mai sa
merde j'ai mis du temps de voir si avec
une autorisation du président auriol un
film d'isild mérité un set était
enceinte attend mère était enceinte
attend depuis l'habiter à nice et
cherchant chaud là bas et tout ça hein
il a été le plus jeune père de famille
ben y en a maintenant elle est plus
jeune de plus le plus jeune bachelier
ong sauter des classes saute-mouton tu
as eu ton by la canadienne j'ai sauté la
cinquième la troisième est la première
c'est incroyable il faut apprendre par
les vacances et aux bergers mémoire par
l'intelligence mémoire banner mois telli
jenson et moi vous entendez
mais moi alors j'ai posé une colle est
ce que tu sais pourquoi les flamands
sont roses mais regarde top tu prends
ton telle étude un budget
il demande
la toolbar
pour voir la vie en rose mieux vaut une
bonne dose d'optimisme et une paire de
lunettes adaptées car dans la nature le
rose n'est pas une couleur très
fréquentes
même les flamands ne sont pas tous aussi
rose que l'on croit dans les eaux on
ajoute un colorant à leur alimentation
pour que tous les flamands ne devienne
pas blanc jeunes des choix qu est à base
de poisson il y avait un peu de carotène
dedans pour qu'ils gardent cette belle
couleur jaune ont besoin parce que dans
la nature vivement certains produits qui
leur accorde cette couleur et que nous
on est obligé d'apporter parce que ici
ils ne l'ont pas autrefois ont régalé
c'est drôle d'oiseau de 40 râpé pour
leur donner bonne mine
mais aujourd'hui dans la plupart des
eaux on préfère la contacter santini un
additif qui ne colorent pas que les
flamands mais aussi les saucisses de
strasbourg
[Musique]
mais si le flamand en captivité a
tendance à perdre ses couleurs la
saucisse de strasbourg elle reste bien
rose même à l'état sauvage
mais passons pas à côté des choses ça
bah écoutez moi je pense que je sais
qu'on on traite des tas de choses
aujourd'hui ont piqué jambon pour les
les rendent bien rose et tout bon ça
c'est dégueulasse on on met des carotène
dans les produits que les nanas se met
sur l'afrique là où sur les nibards pour
les bronzer tranquillement sur la plage
mais ça c est ce qu ils veulent
bon je trouve ça normal mais les pauvres
flamand on leur a rien demandé je trouve
plutôt quand même c'est pas net que les
flamands des chaussons roses grâce aux
colorants des saucisses de strasbourg s
de l'info est de l'intox
attends je vous le demande pendant que
vous réfléchissez que bon hein j'ai
réfléchi anémone et mocky aussi qu'est
ce qu'on écoute corti jordi c'est dur
d'être bébé
tu es trop bébé dur dur d'être bébé
[Musique]
on y cultive ainsi
un statut retrouvé
[Musique]
m
suite
d'être payés quelques très beaux lots
[Musique]
je vous en remercie à tous grâce aux
colorants des saucisses de strasbourg s
de l'info est de l'intox gtel de
mandrichi axe intox pourquoi croit pas
toi parce que j'espère que les flamands
sont roses et chez in the bell non je
crois qu'il soit que c'est vrai parce
qu'ils voient des crevettes dans la
nature votre commun
j'irai atteint faux et toi intox intox
pourquoi parce que les flamands sont
naturellement
c'est un sujet qui nous a été envoyé par
madame françoise santarelli de marseille
qui gagne 2000 francs maintenant pour
savoir si je vais remettre ta poche on
écoute la réponse l'accord taxons tine
c'est un colorant naturel connu
également sous le nom de code e 161 g de
la même famille que les carotène qu'on
le retrouve dans tous les produits
autobronzants on la retrouve dans
plusieurs produits de charcuterie
industrielle et principalement dans la
saucisse de strasbourg c'est ce qui
donne cette coloration rose orangé et on
la retrouve dans pratiquement toutes les
marques que j'ai là sous les yeux c'est
bien marqué sur l'emballage qu'en taxant
tine qui colorent les flamands roses qui
sont en captivité
donc tu as perdu libertés jld et des
roses en liberté ou ici parce qu'ils
mangent des crevettes mais quand ils
seront les eaux on leur donne ce produit
qui est le même rose que celui qui
colore avant les saucisses de strasbourg
anne est pour eux la donne pas des
crevettes et au déjà moi je vais me le
bal de ma poche si en plus il faut filer
les crevettes of l'amour d'aujourd'hui
un don qui prennent assez dense parfois
les toits alors tu avais dit que c'était
en tout cas voilà alors corti le score
et à richard est éliminé mais on a droit
ce soir aux tirs au but entre mots qui
est lemond
j'ai posé une question vais bien c'est
de l'info ou de l'intox l'alsace
produits sains crus d'appellation
contrôlée qui s'appelle le clos sony n'a
pas plus con comme question
le nouveau sony ça sonne pas moche pour
un non exécutoire puisque la vie elle
dit que c'est de l'intox
ben alors moi je dis que je n'ai c'est
de l'info parce que tout le monde
gagnera jamais là il va tu as gagné
parce que c'est un faux profil usine au
milieu des vignobles d'alsace et ils
produisent un vin qu'ils ont baptisé le
clos sony est ce qu on n y voit là
autour de lusine les vignerons usines
produisent un rat qui est mis en
bouteille sous le nom de klaus sony
voilà c'est un film qui arrive s'appelle
toshiba au grisbi
je ramène cet ordinateur
[Musique]
toi
oui
r tout
jean-pierre toi qui as fait le miraculé
un drôle de paroissien ça te fait quoi
te retrouver dans un confessionnal
c'est un lieu que je connais bien parce
que quand j'étais petit j'allais me
confesser maintenant je me confesse lui
beaucoup je crois que c'est la première
fois que je me confesse depuis 50 ans tu
crois que tu es un mécréant un athée
plus tôt alors on va passer aux sept
péchés capitaux est ce que tu pèses par
orgueil
non là je crois pas non je suis plutôt
trop simple remarque c'est une façon
d'être orgueilleux aussi par avarice
oui je suis radin ça tout le monde le
sait mais c'est parce que j'ai pas une
freak au départ parce que tu sais que
les deux réalisateurs sais c'est pas
très bien casque et c'est pour ça on est
peut-être
la luxure par contre beaucoup de lennon
oui pas mal n'ont ils pas mal mais ça
s'arrête pas encore tous ces
championnats disais que quand il avait
90 ans bon il y allait toujours pu enfin
maintenant les partouzes du cinéma avec
le sida c'est un peu fini non ça c'est
terminé maintenant tout le monde a peur
c'était à quelle époque la grande époque
c'était 48 c'est l existentialisme jean
paul sartre les bonnes femmes qui sont
floutés par la fenêtre dans le quartier
saint-germain la travée c'était le début
d'une fille sortait de chez elle elle
allait coucher comme ça chez l'un chez
l'autre ça a commencé comme ça c'est
sartre camus tout ça qu'ils ont menées
sur cette impulsion maintenant c'est un
peu fini puisque le sida tue addition
des mettre bout à bout les bassins de
toutes les femmes que j'ai sauté
ça ferait 200 m dès fier de dire des
trucs pareils oh non ceux d'avant temps
est ce que tu feras le divorce j'ai fait
un film en 66 justement parce que
j'arrivais pas divorcer j'ai mis dix ans
pour divorcer alors et roger remis à
fait divorce à l'italienne monte ou tuer
sa femme s'il pouvait pas s'en sortir
autrement puis moi j'ai fait quelque
chose qui s'appelait le camping
marguerite avec claude rich cho lui il
efface est carrément les actes de
naissance comme ça les gens étaient
divorcés automatiquement le suicide on
peut se suicider tout en continuant à
vivre il faut faire quoi
faire ce qu'on a envie de faire je
suppose quand on en a marre de tout il
faut faire n'importe quoi
il passe tu sers à rien ça fait de la
peine aux autres est ce que tu aimerais
bien la peine de nous en avons tué trois
mecs par an dans la région du nord en
général et pauvre mec alors pour trois
mecs inspirant et la peine de mort c'est
vraiment on n'a jamais condamné à mort
ceux qui méritaient de l'être alors donc
finalement c'est que des lampistes qui
on a exécuté pour la plupart même pour
les as un enfant ça j'aime pas j'aime
pas les assassins d'enfants ça ça peut
être que faudrait les mettre dans un cas
un peu spécial particulier je sais pas
il faudrait parce qu'il faudrait à
fermer la mort donnée la mort je ne sais
pas si quelqu'un a le droit de le faire
et tu favorable au droit de vote pour
les immigrés oui tout le monde a le
droit de voter ça sert à rien de toute
façon tu crois en dieu je te dis que
j'étais athée et mais je crois à quelque
chose mais je voudrais bien savoir
comment on a été créée pourquoi je te
parle en ce moment je voudrais bien
savoir qui c'est qui m'a mis là ceci dit
ce mystère je ne l'est pas je suis
incapable de découvrir de le déceler le
percer à jour alors jean merdé quoi je
me dis quand je serai cannes et qu'est
ce que je vais devenir
est-ce que tu n est tabou
[Musique]
oh
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater le il
a l'habitude abonnez vous y mettez un
peu de bleu